[Music]
in deadly pasta news pasta was gonna be
there somebody put a poison inside now
that's on topic pasta is already deadly
as it is the best pasta I ever had was
in Paris at that one place at me and
Julio and Aaron went to it was a foie
gras foie gras foie gras ravioli with
truffle sauce oh my god it was the whole
thing is pretty good is freshly made oh
my god that's still the best possible
had voice grace I'm gonna have my pasta
food dr. with the oh [ __ ] psych
submitted by the Reaper kill me
[ __ ] a doctor with a youtube
channel recently discovered a strange
food-related death what that one guy
Pavarotti is really covered you said
Visor from eating a lot of bad food like
pasta no see it's a car guy he choked on
a pasta and died Oh Pavarotti's [ __ ]
tight dude Pavarotti and [ __ ] James
Brown they have us they have this
collaborate ones do oh yeah yeah it's
sick man used Pavarotti Pavarotti
you said Pavarotti died cuz he ate a lot
of pasta and I was like I thought you
you mean he choked on a pasta died you
uncultured
I'm colder dislike well yeah jesse is no
he covered Burt
it's strange I've ever received
discovered and I just want to clear it
up my so um yeah so this story is
actually old what's the reason why we're
talking about it now is because this
doctors youtube channel talked about it
recently so the hot one hot one there's
a really hot doctor with a YouTube
channel like I know that's not his name
his name is so fine dr. Bernard Bernard
duffel sounds ugly
that's tight that a babe kid did note
hardware you are Peter wicked see Ursula
Ursula yeah
Ursula Phoebe's twin sisters evil do not
watch that show from all the octopus
yeah which
oh can you go that high can you go like
the [ __ ] air out of a balloon
all the dogs right now let your dogs
listen to this video see what happened
recording sweet sauce meat huh oh you're
thinking my collectors come Maddie does
that when you make a high-pitched noise
she does that it's so cute mmm I like
when they're puppies in the ears still
floppy yeah this is adorable are you
trying to be cross-eyed yeah okay good
all right so this door here is about 20
year old student who died after he ate a
full of spaghetti with tomato sauce that
was made five days early oh he's stupid
so he expired food well I did all the
time and I get a stomach ache here's the
thing
sokeep meal prepped his pasta mmm but
sometimes I he'll forget and he left one
of the containers out hmm
and this stayed out for two days and
then his roommate so anyways because
what I wanted to say is that tell the
story one way but then the doctor in his
video he told the story a different way
that's why I'm like oh I don't know
which one to go in doctor way okay find
the doctor so that doctors video said
that the roommate saw the food out he
thought that it was just made that day
so you put it in the fridge days later
which was by now five days later after
it was made um AJ the students 20-year
old student ate it and then half an hour
later he started vomiting really
violently oh and then his so the doctor
saying that the roommate found him in
the bathroom like bobbing like crazy and
then his eyes turned like yellowish
green and then so then they went took
him to the hospital and in the ambulance
he was throwing up like crazy and then
you got way to go because they were
trying to figure out what was wrong then
they were looking into his liver because
they thought what happened exactly um
but then in the article they say that
poor parents
ones that found him the next morning
that they got worried that he didn't
wake up for college so there's like two
different stories what doesn't make any
sense they're very different stories
it's not even slightly different I don't
I know it's kind of I mean still like
the root of it all though is like he
died from pasta that's still like don't
blame the but no one know what's in the
pasta box ilysm so it was bacillus
Sarris
that's not a Harry Potter spell is it is
it botulism so the article says that the
autopsy revealed that it his death was
linked to that bacillus sera sera
Maskull basilisks I tell you something
I left some chicken out because I forgot
to refrigerate it and I was like I'll
eat it later because we were having a
meeting and then it was out for a good
like we picked it up at one end of the
meeting at 6:00 oh [ __ ]
giggles good for a good five hours I do
this all the time I leave food out i
microwave that [ __ ] zap it eat it
nothing wrong okay
I eat that [ __ ] I'd go home I
don't feel good I try to go to feel good
like maybe I could sleep it off and as
soon as I like wake up from my 20-minute
nap I need to vomit right so then I'm
just puking and puking puking up till
like 1:00 a.m. so my [ __ ] is your
stomach store I've never puked that much
in a long time I usually I was like yeah
right and then go back drink water but
the water goes up and then I chill it's
just a little bit of nothing I'm like
what's going on
drink tea the tea comes out and I wait
and then there was more inside I had no
idea cuz I checked pepto-bismol like
pepto-bismol help me please and I went
and then more food came out and more
food it just kept coming on yeah he was
trying to he try to using pepto to
sometimes [ __ ] so strong pet though
doesn't do anything yeah so they're
saying here that this particular
bacteria can contaminate a wide range of
foods particularly rice and leftovers as
well as sauces soups and other prepared
foods that have been set out too long at
room temp
BAM that's probably what I mean you
[ __ ] so how did he cover um what
do you mean how do you cover Oh cuz he
he talks about medical pieces oh they
covered it like meaning he like reported
on it oh I thought like know like he did
it and tried to cover it up I covered up
that he was guilty for sure no that's
not what she said discovered I'm like no
that's wrong oh by the way too about it
just as a precursor for people out there
that doesn't mean that when your food is
hot you put it in the fridge immediately
for example like you have soups right
that's actually one of the worst things
to do for bacteria yep because it's too
hot it gets cold on the outside and then
becomes room temp in a very very
comfortable bacterial temperature in
there do not do that so wait for it to
go to the room tip and then put it in
yeah sometimes I leave soup I make soup
and and I leave this soup overnight into
the next day and into the dinner time
and I go oh it's been here for almost 24
hours let me blast this [ __ ] up
and I burn the [ __ ] out of it till it's
roaring and boiling and then I eat it
that's what I always do I always do that
if I normally eat the soup the next day
I even put in the fridge I don't know
it's not a good boil the [ __ ] out of it
and I've been doing this my whole life
because I learned it for my grandma food
on the stove all the time and I get only
four hours and you're gonna blast the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on it's good you're
Mexican you're good that's true you have
more survival like bacteria than we do
in this article though you know you just
it says here that the government agency
food safety or goddamn about the
conspiracy foodsafety.gov says that um
it advises people to store cooked food
in a wide shallow container and to
refrigerate it as soon as possible
that's why people Sanders they always
get stomachaches but you can't do it
when it's when it's not hot though
that's like that's like restaurant
standard yeah you cannot do that around
everything in saran wrap and put in the
fridge my family did that yeah they pour
soup in us ran up in the wrath
gabato man good damn I put uh saran wrap
on the bottle but did you guys ever hear
to not put can can in the refrigerator
ya know like spam like if you can't
expand it you put it back in the like a
cat but you opened it he opened the cat
but like there you know but from what
I've heard is that the metal is like
it's not good for the food in your
fridge Oh for real yeah I supposed take
it out and put in Tupperware yeah what
difference does it make because it's in
it's already in the middle for I don't
know how long video because I could tell
you this the other food in your fridge
but what about like bakery pans that
people put in the fridge I could tell
you this every single agent fridge if
they use condensed milk yep that
[ __ ] condensed milk is in the
can in the fridge and the rim is all
dirty with you yes on the side you guys
with pots in your fridge too big cause I
always I always took you like put it in
a Tupperware we have enough tougher
words we try not to put in there cuz
it's such a weird shape that like it
tastes like the handle it takes up so
much so I'll just put in the Tupperware
but I think over overnight for soups or
fighting like for example like like like
gumbo right you make it the night before
yeah because it's so big it's gonna get
to room temp in like 3 to 4 hours it's
gonna take a long [ __ ] time but no
people keep the fire on so that's why
it's my car you won't do that with both
soul - we'd make a big or not we should
make a big a spot and then should we
just leave it even on a low simmer super
low like a crock-pot